hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play mad
father yeah okay sorry about that I got
I'm just staying a little loopy from
playing this game so much
I gotta get past these dolls and get
that gem cuz I didn't think I was gonna
get all the gems before but now I have a
good feeling that I might actually make
it so I do not want to miss out on any
possibility of me getting all the gems
actually I'm I am pretty far away from
all the gym so I may have missed some I
probably have you got I haven't been
able to read the comments as I've been
playing but I probably definitely I most
definitely probably missed some a little
of them but I'm gonna get this one just
to make sure that I can you know just to
say that I can oh I always walk right in
uh
no another they mean - dammit I was not
paying attention they're too busy
talking you guys distracted me that's
why I died there and now I wish there
weren't insta death
golly why did I have to wish for that
all you probably heard me say they were
like oh he's good all you guys
boop boop doop doop boop boop even in
the peripheral of her vision you can be
stabbed in the face well actually in the
gut yep epidemic you get it get it get
it get it okay now hide hide up here
she's not gonna see ya no way no how did
it nope yeah yeah yeah cuckoo for
kalabaw crab no oh what the hell I
wasn't fair at all it's not a bad would
I both another she came charging right
at me was able to know
oh I supposed to do
ah whatever now's a bunch of all there
was a giant pile of baloney baloney okay
I'm gonna get this Jam she's not gonna
stop me from getting the gem that's not
what she's gonna do
I just need to kind of just be kind of
careful in mindful of where I am and
what I'm doing and why I'm doing it now
oh no you know I don't I don't
okay all right so I wasn't expecting
anything else so I'm gonna just good I'm
scared I don't want to go off she's
green now not fair do i do what do i do
you're gonna go bye oh okay huh okay
they can't get me where I am cam just
gonna watch I'm just gonna watch for a
little bit so they're orbiting and
perfectly geosynchronous uh parole
Patrol there I don't know where I need
to go but oh god I didn't die hi yay I
gotta go back no no no oh you can't make
me remember them remember every living
what the dead so it it's dead dollars in
pieces good good oh good good
you mean I could have waited and I could
have got the gem now is that really what
I could have done it could have done
that took you all your down shut up is
there something over here no I don't
like you
please stay dead forever rest in pieces
hey mister here come on out
use the jail key Chicka Chicka yeah
you're free to go
congratulations weirdo yay jump for joy
I got another gem my right the greatest
forever lose okay hi okay sorry buddy
nothing I locked up for a second stop
that okay I'm actually gonna create
multiple save just in case I need to go
back to be able to get something that I
may or may not have missed all right
what's with this big Cathedral like area
and why did that happen
who's in here oh there oh this place is
bigger than I thought it was and run run
a row of pots and oh wait what oh never
mind I thought the musics was like that
the sound of the store moving I was
wrong
hello meets piece of hanging meat rum
rum rum got raw ham right something
small and black wriggles inside no thank
you
up dirty plate no faucet flame is on fry
it up baby let's fry it up if that good
grease go hmm hmm nothing like stinky
fly infested ham all right so now I got
a plate of meat that I'm gonna do come
with you want some food
swarming with bugs why is there kitchen
down here anyway why in the world would
be there be a cafeteria here where am i
setting the plate down what am I doing
with it I'll shut it down where hmm with
you plate don't move
that's my impression of her mmm
I mean you I'll blacken swimming zone
you want to play it up birdy you want
some food
your birdy come on hi all right can I
set it back down there we go okay at
least I can do hi I'm here the Prezi
let's go
yeah but if you can't beat this
y'see
I'll give every spacebar that's not good
I won that right I won that I thought I
won that I did didn't I okay I did uh-oh
what ha fat her uh-oh it's that kid
again
the weirdo kid you've come to hi there
weirdo where were you ah don't worry I'm
your ally I don't believe you
sorry I gave you a fright earlier my
appearance must have surprised you that
wound on your face with the firm my
father don't worry about that that's in
the past everyone has it out for father
because of our hate for your father we
can't be saved time spastically hitting
the space bar I'm skipping some things I
don't mean to so I've come to save you
let us get away from here together I
can't I have to save father
don't go some of these corpses will try
to bring you into death as well you stay
here they will take away your life but I
can't leave father give up on your
father no I'm gonna save him let go
listen to me she asked me to do this she
asked uh whoa what huh
mistress
are you alright
Maria mistress why will you not escape
because Father leave the doctor to me
please you have my word I will bring him
back
so please mistress you must flee
somewhere safe you just walk right over
mari let me go with you
pending happened to you mistress the
doctor would mourn what lies ahead well
I know I must be difficult I shall go
ahead alone I not all on on you whoa ho
ho it would seem that she's coming to
meet me milady you shall not do as you
please I shall settle this you're gonna
fight the dead mother the mad mother
that's one mad mother okay so that poor
kid is now dead or more dead I guess
dead before not moving it's locked I
still need to move forward I still have
this play to hand that I don't know what
to do with I think this pot got broken
open nothing in there though okay
watching oh okay so I may have messed up
there cuz I can't go back now
oh I you're the one that tried to
strangle me huh can't get me too quick
for you too quick too spinny oh okay
that's what up what to do oh I should
have known that before did I get it
hey I got it we know good for me good
for me great can I go back now yeah
let's go right back into it who cares
oh hi mister the passage was a bit
cluttered so I cleaned up a bit you're
welcome you're welcome okay
hi oh yeah they're mannequins oh I
believe that painting of a woman okay
suit of armor I don't trust that Hey hi
oh ho ho I truly appear in unexpected
places
so did you solve the puzzle to open this
door wait a minute
yeah there was this some guy in the same
costume but it was the headless thing
telling me yeah here we go
update empty Cherokee
I got a push I got a Boosh the other one
out of the way with this'n damn it
movie [ __ ] ah crap
I messed up it's not that was wrong that
was wrong it goes over the other side
because and then I need to cut off the
head that's what I need to I had the
order all wrong sorry sorry everybody
this is embarrassing oh my gosh she's so
embarrassing I'm so sorry I I feel so
bad come on come on wait boop-boop-boop
seems like a lot of work for a little
11-year old girl
and where did Maria go she obviously
didn't do very much to help she's not oh
maybe it's like that thing in the
witch's house I got to make the rooms
identical oh hello
not moving lovely soldier mannequin with
a spear okay I got to give a spear to
that guy turn that straight oh I got to
take the spear from that suit of armor
give it to the other guy and I need to
get some flowers from somewhere give me
your spear give me your spear I'm gonna
grab it I'm gonna saw it rum rum rum rum
rum No okay fine be that way do I need a
15 of 21 gems I've got a lot of gems I
need to saw his head off
that's what I need to do yeah it won't
open do I eventually have to go back
Brum take that okay I'm still missing
something I need to go find some flowers
I gotta get this
no I gotta take the spear from that guy
and put it on the soldier that's what I
gotta do I'm dumb put it on the other
give me your spear Ripa doopa doopa
doopa doopa doopa doopa doopa and then I
still gotta find some flowers here you
go thank you
where am I gonna find some flowers here
you are you're where can I find some
clearers were there any live we flew
from high well have I got just the thing
for you here absolutely
asparagus ham ham spare igus okay it's
right here just take it smells like just
like my favorite fried ham yeah I'm 11
year old that can cook great yeah that's
weird
stop eating so creepily mmm so good it
tastes just like mom what I'm disturbing
on multiple level there don't know uh-uh
that don't taste like mom that better
not well not quite - mom standards but
it was pretty tasty I ain't had a bite
to eat since I was locked up here
oh it's Darren Maria always brought food
down to the basement didn't you have
that everyone out for getting food back
mate I always whoa warm morning no you
should just be people go I was banded
yes have this internship with your name
on it
and thankful giving me food here you
will thank the gift you're here right
okay
that's Oh a napkin well it's hardly
gonna help me I still need to go find
flowers are we gonna find flowers in why
shouldn't you go back oh oh well I hope
I didn't miss any jams maybe I can split
the foul flowers in between the two
vases might be something I might be onto
something good luck
oh I got a bouquet there we go alright
this should be the last thing no I I
don't think these sinks through whenever
I'm talking ladies I don't think things
through napkin is there so somewhere
here that a napkin would go wait a
minute whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
move that's right hi dot doh okay the
squish step on the head oh this is
normal my diary's okay Xu arey axe I was
born I slept cuddling up against my
mother
sculpture of baby weird all right what
what am I supposed to do about all that
you want a napkin want a napkin little
kitty you want a napkin what am i doing
come on what what what are we doing what
am i done rum rum rum rum rum
boom okay I don't know why don't know
that's dumb rum rum rum rum rum rum rum
rum rum okay I don't know man and red is
gone what do I do
how did I get bass at I don't know what
to do
what do I look like some got a brainiacs
genius man I'm just a simple youtuber I
don't know where I am
I don't know what to do I'm just a
simple youtuber you want to penned it
you want panting okay I'm on our pendant
I've got a napkin and nothing to do with
it just eternal pressing darkness
I think the insanity has finally gotten
to this little girl and she's going to
die a horrible death very soon just my
opinion probably what's gonna happen I
don't know I don't know I don't know i
don't i still don't think I can go back
like what am I gonna do I can't go back
well I went a minute with him what am I
supposed to do I can't go back I
probably shouldn't go back okay maybe
there was something that I needed to get
with this nappy kin oh hey let me try no
no no no what could I possibly use a
napkin with I'm Way over time I wasn't
even paying attention to the time so
I'll figure this out later so thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye
Oh No Oh
yeah
I'm waiting live bait oh is that
abbreviation mr. monster Freddie
I know
taking gift I guess because reached are
the game can't met again